what's been the biggest misstep in your
YouTube Journey one of the biggest
mistakes or challenges for long-term
creators creators like me with a channel
that is 2.5 million subscribers and it's
13 years
old I think what can be hard with a
really older channel is how diverse your
content is and as a result how much that
can mix up who your subscribers are let
me give you an example we have a video
posted
on um a Final Cut Pro
tutorial so that's great watch this it's
on brand because it's the best tips and
tools for growing your influence with
online video what's one of the tools
Final Cut what's one of the ways to do
it Final Cut it's a net positive but the
problem is um if you think really deeply
about this stuff over years and
decades if someone watches that one
video though and they click subscribe
there may not be another video that
comes out from think media that they
actually want to watch and that can C
cause a problem we've obviously survived
our company is heavier healthier than
ever the bigger picture of the game
we're playing it's totally fine but the
the reality
is that even your Niche within a niche
played out over time can just create a a
an an audience of subscribers that's
still a little bit mixed every time you
go a little bit off of brand or your
core core core brand there's another way
to put it and but here's the thing I
don't regret it and honestly we still do
it it's like this is why I'm glad we
have hundreds of thousands of emails in
specific categories of people so you're
asking it's not that as a business we
are not if you we tagging and
categorizing and thinking about who
we're talking to it's that on YouTube
it's a giant mix so in a YouTube video
you can invite somebody to something
that lets you know exactly who they are
oh this is a group of real estate agents
this is a group of mothers this is a
group so there's like also ways to solve
that but that's YouTube
specific um and I think also thinking
about how to solve that is what are
people being invol invited to meaning
what is the long-term this is why like
my friend's coauthor of YouTube Secrets
Benji Travis and his wife Judy Travis
they actually still have a family Vlog
that's over 10 years old why people are
invested in the characters harder to do
but you're not just you're not invested
as much as in a paino you're actually
following a character Evolution sounds
funny when we're talking about like
reality TV like a vlog but if you can
pull that off then you could have fans
that have watched you for 10 years now
mind you I have fans that have watched
me for 10 years as well but what videos
do they click on what and and so I'm all
those are some of the questions so it's
not even really a misstep this is all
educational for me and I can pass along
those learnings to you this is why I'm
excited about this very think media
podcast channel for the time being it is
more Focus and more dialed in than even
our other channel and even with only
130,000 subscribers it's interesting to
see some of the results some of the
views why because it's also fresh by the
way this opportunity for new
creators it's a blessing to grow a new
Channel right now now mind you it's a
blessing to have a million subscribers
as well but not everything is always
what it seems
some we actually went through an
experiment once where we took over a
channel that had 100,000 subscribers and
we saw it wasn't as powerful as you
think the question is who are the
subscribers what is it they wanted to
watch what are you know you can have
quote unquote a dead Channel there's
ways to revive it but there's always
different metrics behind the scenes so
that's one to think about I think the
takeaways for all of us and is to think
about what is it we're building who is
subscribing why are they subscribing in
some niches it's accepting that it might
be temporary and you're not watching
think media if you're looking for a
camera you weren't subscribing like you
were to follow Benji and J's Vlog you're
look you want to watch the evolution of
their family their marriage and their
kids what are they subscribing for you
like their personality you're you know
Filipino as well you kind of like the
culture you want to see different things
those are all value
propositions I have to be okay with my
friend told me one
time Chase and CH Jason Chelsea said
Sean here's why I hate think
media you ready for this that's a great
way for your friend to open a sentence
hey Sean here's why I hate think
media I watched your channel
religiously for four months because I
wanted to upgrade my camera equipment
okay go on Jace and it was so helpful I
figured out exactly what camera
equipment I wanted to buy what
microphone what gear and then I ordered
it all and I Ed your affiliate links
thanks bro I appreciate you so uh are
you going to get to the hate part
because so far this is pretty positive
but I'm really nervous for what's coming
next next so he said but then after 4
months after I ordered the camera and I
had it shipped to my house I made a
conscious decision I wasn't going to
watch your channel anymore and I was
like ouch bro like why he goes because I
realized you're always talking about the
newest thing and the newest camera and I
didn't want to have fear of missing out
because now I have my camera and I
watched the tutorial of how to use it so
now I'm just going to go do the work and
thank you but I don't want to be
reminded that there's a new Sony camera
out and and so by the way in terms of
ideation and insight this is why as much
conversations with actual audience
members as you can be and give you
invaluable insights because the Creator
who understands the viewer best
wins so then I started thinking two
things one how do I solve that problem
two being okay with okay in a lot of
ways think media is can be
transitory people come for a while they
learn
they get what they need they go
execute and so they might not be as
active as a subscriber as somebody this
is why there's a million dooll YouTube
question what content could you create
on YouTube that would make viewers want
to come back and genuinely watch every
day you don't have to do that I'm just
saying it if you if you have a good
answer to that question that actually
works you've created one of the most
valuable things in the world what
content could you create on YouTube that
people would want to watch for the next
5 to 10 years not everyone can answer
that and you don't even have to you
might go my Niche doesn't fit in that
totally fine just when you if you think
about brand and Legacy those are some
interesting thought exercises okay do
people come to my channel to learn one
thing get the answer to the question and
move on if that's true that's fine but
you should adapt accordingly okay so I
do definitely need new acquisition to
keep growing because people will pass
through is this more of they stick with
me and I'm trying to build a fan base
okay that's interesting and will the fan
base age out and will there need to be
new acquisition or could I like build a
mob that roles with me for the next 5 to
10 years if you enjoy this podcast and
are ready for some deep dive YouTube
strategy just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to my
one-hour OnDemand YouTube strategy class
you'll be looking over my shoulder as I
share my best tips and you can watch it
on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com